شكرا جمال مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا ابرز
العناوين في هذه التغطيه
سيول ليبيا تغمر قرى باكملها في الشرق
وتمح ربع مدينه درنه والحصيله مصرع اكثر
من خمسه الاف
واستمرار عمليات البحث والانقاذ عن الاف
في عداد المفقودين
وفي المغرب عمليات البحث والانخاف تتواصل
بحثا عن ناجينا من زلزال الحوز
اليونسف تقول ان حول مئه الف طفل تاثروا
بالزلزال والعهد المغربي يزور المصابين في
مستشفى مراكش
اصابه مستوطنين باطلاق نار في بلده حواره
جنوبي نابلس قوه الاحتلال تماشيط المنطقه
بحثا عن منافذ العمليه بعد فراره واحماس
تصف العمليه بالرد على ممارسات الاحتلال
بحق الاسرى والمسجد الاقصى
[موسيقى]
البدايه مع تغطيتنا للتطورات السيول في
درنا الليبيه
[موسيقى]
اذا قتل الالاف ولا يزال الاف اخرون في
عداد المفقودين جراء السيول التي ضربت
مدنا في الشرق الليبي كانت الحصيله الاكبر
في مدينه درنه فقد قالت وكاله الانباء
الليبيه ان عدد القتلى تجاوز خمسه الاف
وثلاث مئه بينما يقدر عدد المفقودين
بالالاف كما قال مسؤولون بالاتحاد الدولي
لجمعيات صليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر ان
نحو عشره الاف شخص في عداد المفقودين بعد
سيول والفيضانات العالمه
هذا واظهر مقطع فيديو بثته منصه محليه في
مدينه درنه انتشار عدد كبير من الجثث في
منطقه شيحه بالمدينه في انتظار التعرف على
هويتها كما بفى سكان وناشطون مناشدات من
داخل مقبره المدينه لارسال اليات حفر
للتمكن من دفن الجثث
واظهرت مشاهد جويه حصلت عليها الجزيره
اثار دمار هائل لاحياء باكملها في مدينه
دارنا الليبيه سببتها سيول وتظهر المشاهد
دمار العديد من المنازل والممتلكات
والمنشات في المدينه الساحليه وغيبت سيول
احياء كامله في مدينه درنا الليبيه
من جهته وصفه هشام ابو شكيوات وزير
الطيران المدني في الحكومه المكلفه من
البرلمان وعضو لجنه الطوارئ في مدينه درنه
وصف الوضع بالخطير والكارثي وفي مقابلات
مع الجزيره قال ان دمنا اصبحت غير صالحه
للسكن وان الجثث منتشره في كل مكان
كارثي عادل الضحايا يزيد في الدقيقه ان
العدد سوف يتجاوز
هرعت فرق الانقاذ وفرق الجيش للمنطقه
دارنا المنكوبه منذ فتره امس وما زالت
تتعامل مع الوضع في عمليه الانقاذ وانتشار
الجثث الليبيين تناسب مشاكلهم وتناسل
الانقسام اللي موجود وحبه لي بكل حد وصوب
من ارض البلاد ومن شرقها لمساعده اخوانهم
في مدينه درنه لانه عدد المفقودين كبير
شويه يعني ومبسوط اكثر من 24 ساعه يعني
صعب
احياء يعني الجزء المحيط بالمنطقه
المنكوبه التي هي جربها
الفيضان اخليت تماما
وسيطرت عليها قوات
الجيش
وقسمته مربعات تتعامل معها في عمليه اخلاء
الجثث ولكن اعتقد المدينه غير صالحه للسكن
الان
قال رئيس حكومه الوحدات الوطنيه عبد
الحميد الدبيبه ان ليبيا بحاجه الى معدات
متطوره تمكن فرق البحث من الوصول الى
الضحايا الذين جرفتهم السيول الى البحر
عندنا عدد
ما كل التواضع المسؤول البشريه ولا حتى
الامارات
وتحت السيطره ويشوفوا ويخدموا يوم نحتاجه
الى اي اجهزه الاجهزه هي مرات هل نطلبها
بدون اي
حشمه ولا بنستعمله ولا بدون مواربه نحن
نطلب الدعم مش لاجل الدعم يطلب الاجل في
الدعم
لامور اللي هو محتاجينها فقط
واكدت بيبا ان اكثر من 400 سيارات اسعاف
تمكنت من دخولي مدينه درنه للمساعده في
عمليات اجلاء المصابين والضحايا واكد في
مقابله مع الجزيره ان فرق الانتشار البحري
الليبيه بدات العمل في البحث عن جثث
الضحايا في البحر
الحمد لله
400 سياره اسعاف اللي هو عند المشكله في
انشاء الجثث من البحر وهذا
قاعدين حتى البحريه الليبيه وبعض الغواصين
وبعض الضفادع البشريه قاعدين يحاولوا بكل
جهد فيه الجدد عمليه البحث الجنائي داير
الدوله كيف ما قلنا والامور ملناش مرتاحين
ولكن بعون الله
نجتاز هذه المرحله
معنى من تاجراء شرق طلب نص مراسله الجزيره
احمد خليفه احمد ما هي اخر المعلومات
المتوفره اولا عن عمليات البحث
والانقاذ وايضا نشاهد خلفك صور تجميع
المساعدات العينيه لارسالها للمناطق
المنكوبه بالسيول
بالنسبه للوضع الميداني في درنه حسن الان
الكهرباء بدات تعود تدريجيا بشكل تدريجي
الى المدينه منذ مساء مستعمل الفرق الفنيه
بشركه الكهرباء على اعاده التيار
الكهربائي الى المدينه ونجحت في ذلك بشكل
جزئي ما عدا الاماكن او المواقع التي
دمرها هذا هذه السيوله وهذه الفيضانات
ايضا ما يتعلق
بالتغطيه تغطيه الهواتف او الاتصالات
عادتي الاخرى بشكل تدريجي الى المدينه
النقطه الاخرى الان هناك تخوفات في
المدينه من تحلل الجثث الموجوده تحت
الركام وتحت الطمي باعتبار انها الان مره
عليها 48 ساعه في ظروف جويه معينه الطقس
عاده الى طبيعته اليوم ليبيا تشهد شهدت في
النهار جوا صحوا حار بعض الشيء فهناك
تخوفات من تحلل هذه الجثث وبالتالي انتشار
الامراض وهناك دعوات بين اهالي المدينه
الى عدم الدخول الى المواقع التي توجد
فيها
الجثث في المناطق التي اجتاحتها السيول
خصوصا وان هناك ناجين من هذه السيول خرجوا
الى مناطق اخرى في مدينه درنه والان
يريدون العوده الى المناطق التي كانوا
يعيشون فيها
لمعاينتها رغم ان الخسائر كبيره وفادحه
جدا فيما يتعلق بالكلفه البشريه اعداد
الضحايا تزداد كل يوم هذا اليوم حسن لا
ليست لدينا حتى الان معلومات بش احصائيات
الجثث التي عثر عليها اليوم لكن وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي مليئه بالاخبار التي
تتحدث عن اعداد الجثث
واعداد العائلات التي
لقيت حتفها في هذه السيول هناك نقطه اخرى
وهي ان البحر ساحل البحر او مياه البحر
بدات تلفظ بعض الجثث التي رمتها السيول او
مياه السيول في اثناء اندفاعها قادمه من
جنوب دارنا من المرتفعات الجبليه في مدينه
درنه باتجاه سد باتجاه وادي دارنه
وبالتالي جرفت معها كل شيء ورمت هذه الجثث
الان الجثث بدات تلفظها مياه الابحاث
البحر وخصوصا في الشاطئ الشرقي تحديدا
لمدينه درنه حيث ظهرت او طفت على المياه
بعض الجثث اليوم
شكرا لك احمد خليفه من تاجراء شرق طرابلس
للاطلاع اكثر على الاوضاع في درنا وايضا
بالنسبه
للضحايا والاعداد
وعمليات الانقاذ وانتشال الضحايا معنا من
بنغازي هشام ابو شكيوات وزير الطيران
المدني في الحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان
وعضو لجنه طوارئ سيد هشام هلا وضعتنا في
صوره ما يجري حاليا في درنا الوضع في
المدينه ماذا عن محاولات سحب الجثث مع
الخطر الكامل في حال بقائها في الشوارع
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
تحياتي لكل الاخوه المشاهدين لازال الوضع
الاساوي القائم في درنه ما زالت الفرق
الانقاذ وفرق البحث
وقوات الجيش
في مسرح العمليات تحاول
انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه من الاحياء الموجود
تحت الالقاد وتحت الاقوام
المباني الوضع ليس بالسهل الوضع يزداد
تعقيدا حجم الضحايا في زياد واضح تجاوز ال
5,500 قتيل
هذه اخر احصائيه حوادث عصر هذا اليوم
العدد سوف يتجاوز هذا الرقم للاسف الشديد
لان عدد المفقودين عدد كبير كذلك
فرق الانقاذ تتسابق مع الزمن
لانتشار الجثث منعا لحدود كارثه بيئيه
اخرى
الوضع الحقيقه يعني ما شاهدته يعني حرج
جدا
وصعب علينا لم يشهد مثل هذه الاوضاع
الماساويه منذ قبل
اعتقد مساعدات الدوليه بدات تصل الى مسرح
العمليات
متوقع
انفع عدد الضحايا غدا من صباحا بحكم ان
الاجواء
اصبحت الطقس اصبح عادي الشمس مشرقه وحاله
البحر هادئه
فمتوقع
العدد سوف يرتفع اكثر منها نعم كم عدد
المفقودين المقدر حتى الان
الاف ولكن لا توجد بيانات دقيقه في ظل هذا
الوضع المربك وفي ظل التزاحم على عمليات
القائد لا يوجد رقم دقيقه استطيع ان اجوح
به الهواء واكل الملف
طيب ما هي التحديات الان بالنسبه
لعمليات الانقاذ من جانب والبحث ايضا عن
الجثث وانتشالها من جانب اخر
يعني اوضحت
القوات الجيش
والانقاد يعني في سباق مع الزمان هل على
كل الليبيين من سكان مدينه درنه والمناطق
المجاوره ومن اقصى الغرب لتقديم المساعده
والخدمه وتقديم يد العون حتى في عمليات
الانقاذ ولكن حجم الكارثه كبير حجم الدمار
كبير يحتاج منا وقته مجهودات وفرق وخبر
وخبرات دوليه لها باع في هذا المجال للاسف
الليبيين لم يتعرض لمثل هذا الحدث جلل
لذلك اعتقد المهمه صعبه علينا وممكن تاخذ
وقت اكثر حتى نتجاوز هذا
المصاب الجلاء ونستطيع ان نحصر كل
الجثث وتدخن وان نتعرف عليه المفقودين
ونضع حد للرقم هذا رقم الضحايا اعتقد سوف
ياخذ بعض الوقت طيب سبق وان ذكرت في تصحيح
لك ان مدينه درنه لم تعد مدينه صالحه
للسكن
هذا التصريح غير دقيق انا ما قلته ان 25%
من مدينه درنه تعرضها للدمار يعني صعب
يعني هناك من يقول انا 25% اختفى من من من
على وجه الارض 25 في الميه تعرض لدمار
كبير جدا نتيجه الفيضانات التي التي يعني
الغت بعض المساكن واخفتها بالارض والبعض
الاخر موجود ولكن مدمر ولكن المياه
اخترقته وغير صالح
للسكن احداث صيانه يحتاج عمليات
ترميم اعاده الكهرباء اعاده شبكات الصرف
الصحي يعني هي فيضانات لا تترك ومراها شيء
صالح للاستعمال بعده
هل يمكن القول يعني ان حجم الكارثه في
درنه تحديدا يفوق قدرات السلطات المحليه
الموجوده حاليا وبالتالي هي بحاجه الى
مساعدات تقول المساعدات الدوليه بدات
بالوصول
نعم حجم الكارت كبير
القدرات المحليه والقدرات الوطنيه لا تدخر
جهد
لاستيعاب هذا الوضع ولكن حجم الكارثه كبير
جدا
والامكانيات محدوده لذلك المساعدات
الدوليه والفرق الدوليه مرحب بها وقد بدات
تصل على فكره بدات اتصل صباح هذا اليوم
ومساء اليوم سوف تصل بعض المساعدات من
مجموعه من الدول شقاء جمهوريه مصر العربيه
الامارات تركيا قطر ايطاليا بدت بعض
المساعدات تصل وبدت حتى بعد فرق
القائد وصلت
وتوجهت مباشره الى مسرح العمليات وتشارك
الفرق الانقاذ والجيش في عمليه الانقاذ
وعمليه التعرف على الجثث والمفقودين
هشام ابو شهيوات وزيره طيران المدني في
الحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان وعضو لجنه
الطوارئ من بنغازي شكرا جزيلا لك
ومن درنا معنى المهندس اسلام عزوز عضو
الهيئه الليبيه للاغاثه فرع دارنا السيد
اسلام بمعنى كانت تحدثنا
من درنه مباشره اخبرنا عن الوضع في
المدينه
وصف لنا ما يحصل حاليا خصوصا على مستوى
عمليات الاغاثه
وسحب الجثث او حتى انقاذ من يمكن انقذه
ايوه السلام عليكم اولا نترحم على
ارواح الضحايا الذين وقعوا نتيجه لهذه
الكادحه الطبيعيه
ونسال الله الشفاء العاجل لجرحى والعوده
اليسرى والميمونه لكل المفقودين بالنسبه
لما حصل مدينه دارنا تعتبر كارثه كارثه
طبيعيه تحدث لاول مره في تاريخ ليبيا
ارتفاع عدد الضحايا الى
5220 ضحيه الى ما قبل ثلاث ساعات من الان
هذه الاحصائيه الاخيره عدد المفقودين
تجاوز 823 مفقود بالنسبه للجرحى تجاوز
العدد 7000 جريح موزعين على مستشفيات مركز
طبرق الطبي وبعض المساحات والمستشفيات في
المناطق المجاوره لمدينه درنه الاجهزه
الامنيه والجيش الليبي وفريق الاغاثه
والانقاذ حاليا تقوم بدورها اليوم لاحظنا
دخول الطيران العمودي في عمليه انقاذ
ولاحظنا ايضا
وجود بعض الجثث تم رمها
نتيجه حركه الموج على الشاطئ البحر تم
الانتشال بعض الجثث وتم التعرف عليها وتمت
عمليه الدفن في مقورتين اللي هي مقبره
اظهار الحمر ومقبره مرتبه بالنسبه لحجم
الكارثه وحجم الامكانيات الموجوده
فالدوله الليبيه بكل صدق وبكل امانه قدمت
ما عليها ولكن للاسف شديد يعني لازم من
وجود تدخل او دعم خارجي يقوم بمسانده اهل
مدينه درنه والحكومات الليبيه
بشطرها شرق غربا
نطالب ايضا بتسريع عمليات الانقاذ
لانتشال الجثث لانها كيف تعلم ان اللص في
الضحايا الموجودين على القيمه تحت المباني
المهدمه في شوارع مدينه درنه نسبه الضرر
في المدينه تجاوزت 25%
هذا كلام يعني من وقع الحال الموجود قطاع
يعني كافه سبل الحياه في المناطق المتضرره
كهرباء مياه ملازم مدمره شوارع مغلقه
وللاسف الشديد هناك بعض الاسر تم نقلها
الى المستشفيات
وبعض الاسر النازحه تم نقلها الى المدارس
وخارج المدينه
اصبحوا علما بلا اي اعاشه او اعاده هناك
نقص في المواد الصحيه والادويه
والاعاشه والاغطيه وبعض المستلزمات الخاصه
طب
لنتحدث اكثر عن عمليات الاغاثه بالتحديد
ما هي المشاكل التي تواجه الان فرق
الاغاثه والانقاذ حاليا
المشاكل بصراحه وكل صدق هي قله الامكانيات
المتمثله في الاليات التي تساعد في عمليه
انتشال او عمليه
جرف المباني المهدمه لاستخراج الجثث من
تحتها هناك نقص في الامكانيات نقص في
المعدات والاليات الحفر هناك نقص خبره
برضو يعني نقص خبره الناس كل مطوعه حاليا
بدون خبره يعني ناس تتطوع
از وطني سواء من وحدات الجيش الزمنيه
الهلال الاحمر الكشاف وللعلم فقد غلاء
الاحمر عندنا بعض شهداء تم فقد هم وتم
اكتشافه مالهم اثناء عمليه الانقاذ
نعم
انت معنا طبعا نشكر الجمهوريه الجزائريه
جمهوريه مصر العربيه وجمهوريه تركيا على
تقديم المساعدات وايصال طائرات الاغاثه
بشكل عاجل الى من المطار الابرق ومطار
مرطوبه
وبنغازي فنتمنى ان تستعجل تلك في عمليه
الانتشار الجثث نظرا
لبدء تحلل جثث بعد مرور 48 ساعه مثل ما
المهندس اسلام عزوز عضو الهيئه الليبيه
للاغاثه فرع درنه شكرا جزيلا لك حدثتنا من
مدينه درنه
يحل دانيال على مدن الساحر الليبي لساعات
فيغادرها مخلفا ورائه مدنا منكوبه الكارثه
اشد وقعا في دارنا بعد 24 ساعه تنجلي من
سماء المدينه سحب العاصفه المتوسطيه
ليتضح حول الكارثه ملامح مدينه كل ما تبقى
درنا مدينه منكوبه تقول السلطات هناك ربع
مساحتها اختفى انها اكبر كارثه طبيعيه تحل
على ليبيا منذ زلزال المرج عام
1963 في الخامس من سبتمبر الجرجتاحت
العاصفه دانيال سواحل اليونان وكانت
العاصفه الاقوى التي تضرب البلاد منذ عام
1930 بعد ظهر الاحد توجهت العاصفه الى
السواحل الافريقيه للبحر المتوسط كانت
ليبيا المحطه الاولى للعاصفه فاجتاحت
بدايه المنا الشرقيه لمدينه بنغازي قبل ان
تتحرك شرقا الى منطقه الجبل الاخضر يقول
مركز الارصاد الجويه ان العاصفه العاتيه
كانت مصحوبه بامطار غزيره تجاوزت 400
ملليمتر وهي كميه لم تسجل منذ اربعين عاما
فاجتاحت سيور العاصفه كامله منطقه الجبل
الاخضر وكبرى مدنه مثل درنه والبيضاء
والمرج وشحات وسوسه بالاضافه لقرن وبلدات
بالمنطقه لكن الكارثه الحقيقيه كانت في
مدينه درنه حيث يوجد سد وادي درنا الكبير
بارتفاع 40 مترا وياليه
الضغط الهائل للمياه ولاسباب فنيه في بنيه
السد انهار سد وادي درن الكبير وسرعان ما
لحق به السد الثاني لتتدفق كميات ضخمه من
المياه محمله بالطين ما يضاعف قدرتها
التدميريه تبتلع الفيضانات مدينه درنه وت
معها كلما يقف في طريقها وكل معالم
المدينه تقول السلطات في منطقه الجبل
الاخضر ان السيول غمرت نحو 20 الف كيلو
متر مربع في المنطقه الاف من السكان ما
زالوا في عداد المفقودين اما الضحايا فلا
حصيله دقيقه لهم الهلال الاحمر الليبي في
بنغازي يوثق نزوح 20 الف عائله من مدينه
درنه والاف المفقودين الاخرين خصوصيه درنا
كانت سببا في فاجعتها فهي تتكئ على الجبل
الاخضر وتقابل البحر المتوسط فمن الجبل
تدفقت امواج المياه العاتيه فجرفت احياء
كامله بسكانها والقت بهم في ظلمات البحر
انا من
مدير الطوارئ للمكتب الاقليميه بمنظمه
الصحه العالميه مرحبا بك سيد كيف تراقب او
تتابع منظمه الصحه العالميه تلك الكارثه
التي حلت بدرنه جراء السيول
نعم الوضع في ليبيا بشكل عام وخصوصا في
منطقتي مدينه درنه هو كارثي بكل مال
الكلمه من معنى نعرف ان هناك على الاقل
2100 قتيل وعشره الاف مفقود وعشرين الف او
اكثر من النازحين
وعلى الاقل ثلاث مستشفيات لا تعمل
ومستشفيات فقط يعملان بشكل جزئي وبالتالي
هناك عدد من الموظفين في بنغازي وانضموا
الى وزاره الصحه وقاموا بتقييم اليوم
للوضع والوضع فظيع في المنطقه منظمه الصحه
العالميه سوف تشارك مع وكالات الامم
المتحده المختلفه في تقييم مفصل للاوضاع
في الايام المقبله اذا الوضع صادم ويتعين
علينا
الاف وهذه ارقام ايضا مرشحه للارتفاع سيد
ريتشارد
هل من خطه الطوارئ وضعتها منظمه الصحه
العالميه وبدات العمل
عليها يعني قلت
يتعين علينا القيام بكذا وكذا وكذا لكن هل
من خطه الطوارئ بدا العمل بها بالفعل
نحن نضع دائما خطط في حالات الطوارئ وخطط
الطوارئ للاستجابات في هذه الحالات موجوده
في كل مكاتب المنظمه الصحه العالميه في كل
البلدان ولدينا تواجد في ليبيا لم نكن
نتوقع كارثه بهذا الحجم في ليبيا بنسبه
الى هذا الفيضان الذي حصل ولكن الخطط
كانت موجوده وشاركنا في التقييم الاولي مع
وزاره الصحه في ليبيا وقد حركنا الفرق
ونحن في طور القيام بذلك
لتحرك في حاله الطوارئ في ليبيا ونتحرك من
المراكز
الاقليميه
المجاوره ولدينا ايضا اعاده تحديد لمهامي
الموظفين من طرابلس وبنغازي للمساعده
وعندما يكون لدي تقييم مفصل بشكل اكبر سوف
يكون لدينا خطه هادفه ومحدده بشكل اكبر
حتى الان خطط الطوارئ تعمل بشكل جيد برايي
ولكن الان يتعينوا علينا ان نحدد خططه
محدده تاخذ بعين الاعتبار الوقائع
الميدانيه التي نراها في الميدان وهذا ما
نعمل عليه الان
بالتاكيد تبعت وضع الجثث
المطموره تحت المنازل وفي وتحت الطمي
وايضا تلك التي جرفتها المياه الى البحر
والبحر يعود ليلفظها الى الى شاطئ ما مدى
خطوره هذا الوضع خصوصا اذا ما شهدت مدينه
درنه ارتفاعا في درجات الحراره واستمرار
الجثث في الشوارع
هناك
خاطر متعدده في المجال الصحي الان
وفرق البحث والانقاذ تعمل
ووصلت وتبحث عن ناجينا محتملين تحت الركام
وتحت الانقاذ مع مرور الساعات كما شاهدنا
ايضا في الزلزال في المغرب مع مرور
الساعات ان فرص ايجاد الاحياء تحت الركام
تتراجع يتعين علينا ان نستمر بالعمل في
جهود الانقاذ بالنسبه الى الجثث هي عاده
لا تشكل مخاطر مرتبطه بالصحه العامه عاده
ما لا تشكل مصدر لانتشار الاوبئه ولكن بكل
تاكيد يجب التعامل معها بكرامه انسانيه
بشكل يحفظ الكرامه الانسانيه واخذنا بان
اعتبار الجانب
التقليدي المحليه ولكنها لا تشكل المخاطر
الصحيه نتحدث عن مخاطر مرتبطه
المياه هو التضرر المنشات المرتبطه
بالمياه وكما تفضلت الحراره ترتفع والناس
يقتظون في اماكن وهنا نخشى ان يتم انتشار
الاوبئه المختلفه والامراض المختلفه
المرتبطه بالامراض الجلديه
وفي الجهاز الهضمي وايضا خصوصا بالنسبه
الى الاطفال الذين يمكن ان يكونوا اكثر
عرضه ولذلك
الاستجابه يجب ان تكون شامله بالاضافه الى
جهود البحث والانقاذ والامداد الطبي نحن
بحاجه الى تامين الطعام والمياه
والماوى نحن نعمل مع الحكومه ومع الشركاء
الامم المتحده لكي نتاكد من ايصال هذه
المساعدات ومواجهه هذه المخاطر المشكله
الكبرى بالنسبه الينا هي ان نصل
بالمتخصصين من فرقنا الى البلاد هناك
سلسله من التاخيرات عاده للوصول الى ليبيا
ولكن نحاول ان نتعامل مع هذه المشكله الان
شكرا جزيلا لك ريتشارد برينين مدير
الطوارئ للمكتب الاقليمي بمنظمه الصحه
العالميه احدثتنا من القاهره
الان مشاهدينا الى التطورات في المغرب في
خامس ايام كارثه الزلزال
[موسيقى]
الجهود مستمره سعيا للوصول الى احياء تحت
الركام في المناطق المتضرره من زلزال مساء
الجمعه الماضيه وفي اخر المستجدات افادت
وزاره الداخليه المغربيه بارتفاع عدد قتل
الزلزال الى
2901 والمصابين الى
5530 هذا وتواصل السلطات العموميه شهودها
لانقاذ واجلاء الجرحى وتكفل بالمصابين من
الضحايا وفتح الطرق التي تضررت جراء
الزلزال
النظره من عدن مختلفه من هنا يتبدى حجم
الماساه ونطاقها ليس من شك في ان
الانهيارات الارضيه وتضرر الطرق تزيد من
مشقه التدخل الاغاثي حيث نظر الزلزال
دماره لكن درك الملكي المغربي وصل الى
القرى المنكوبه الوعره باعالي جبال الاطلس
تظهر الصور التي وزعها الدرك جانبا من
مهمه عناصره لتوزيع المساعدات في تلك
المناطق
يشارك اولئك العناصر ايضا في التكفل
بالمصابين العالقين هناك ويشرف على عمليات
اجلائهم جوا الى المستشفيات
ليس الى مشافي المدن الكبرى فحسب فثمت مشى
في الميدانيه انشاها الجيش المغربي لعلاج
جرح المناطق النائيه كهذا المقام في قريه
اسني باقليم الحوز المنكوب الى جنوب مراكش
تقدم هنا الرعايه الطبيه لحالات الاصابه
كافه جراء زلزال والقادمه من كل القرى
والبلدات المجاوره
راماكسون
[موسيقى]
يقول الجيش المغربي انه يساعد في توفير
مياه الشرب وتوزيع الاغذيه والخيام
والاغطيه على الناجين من كارثه الزلزال
اولئك الذين توزعوا على ماوي مؤقته بعد
فقدهم منازلهم بشكل كامل او جزئي بحسبه
معاناه ما الم بهم من صدمه
صافي
غير بعيد عن المراكز الايواء المؤقته
مواقع تذكر بهول المصاب ما تزال فرق البحث
والانقاذ المحليه والعربيه والدوليه تحاول
الوصول الى احياء محتملين تحت الركام لا
تتاثر الجهود مع ان كلا هنا يعلم بان
منسوب الامل في العثور على ناجين اخذ في
التراجع هذه قريه انوجال او ما بقي منها
وتلك فرق مغربيه وقطريه اسبانيه تعمل على
انتشال جثامين ضحايا الزلزال من تحت
بنايات منهاره
تعززت اذا عمليات البحث ورفع الانقاض
بمشاركه فرق مختصه او فدتها الدول التي
وافق المغرب على عروض المساعده التي
قدمتها
ستجد بين اهالي اكثر المناطق قربا من مركز
الهزه الارضيه من ينتقدون بطء جهود
الانقاذ والاغاثه بعضهم في المناطق
النائيه والمعزوله يقولون انهم متروكون
لمصيرهم غير ان طبيعه التضاريس هنا
والاضرار التي لحقت بالطرق والمسالك
الجبليه لم تسهل مهمه السلطات مع بدايه
محنه الزلزال الان وقد جرى تدارك الامر
تزداد احتياجات المئات ممن شردهم زلزال
مسائل جمعه العنيف كلما طال مقامهم في
العراء او في مراكز الايواء المؤقته لن
يطول الامر تطمئن الحكومه المغربيه
ستتكفل كما قالت بعد تقييم الموقف باعاده
اعمار المناطق المنكوبه
وقال عضو البرلمان ورئيس مقاطعه مراكش
المناره عبد الواحد الشافقي انه يصعب
تحديد ارقام بشان اعداد الضحايا في الوقت
الحالي موضحا ان صعوبات التي تعوق عمل فرق
الانقاذ تتمثل في وعوره المناطق الجبليه
التي ضربها الزلزال واكد شافقي في حديث
للجزيره ان السلطات المحليه مستمره في
جهود الاغاثه وتقديم المساعدات اللازمه
صعوبه كثيره خصوصا وان
المنطقه كما قلت انها منطقه جبليه ومنطقه
واعره وصعبه المسالك هذا هذا شكل عائقا
امام تقدم جهود الانقاذ في مختلف المناطق
خصوصا وان جل المسالك وجبن الطرقات التي
هي غالبها غير معبده قد دمرها الزلزال
هناك صعوبه وهناك مجهودات من طرف الدوله
ومن طرف المسؤوليه
الانقاذ بمختلف مستوياتها سواء كانت تلك
التي
تنتمي الى اجهزه الدوله او تلك التي اتت
من مناطق مختلفه من عبر العالم من طرف من
دول شقيقه وصديقه
هذا وزاره العاهل المغربي الملك محمد
السادس المستشفى الجامعي بمدينه مراكش
وتفقد المصابين من ضحايا الزلزال الذي ضرب
اقليم الحوز يوم الجمعه الماضيه واظهرت
صور بثات تلفزيون الرسمي تجوال العائله
المغربي في عدد من اقسام المستشفى وغرف
المرضى واستفساره عن اوضاعهم الصحيه
ومستوى الخدمات الصحيه المقدمه واختتم
الملك محمد السادس زيارته للمستشفى بتبرع
للدم بالدم لضحايا الزلزال يذكر ان
مستشفيات مراكش استقبلت حسن مسائي امس
الاثنين نحو 21 مصاب من ضحيه الزلزال من
بينهم حوالي 500 من الذين تعرضوا لاصابات
بليغه
وفي تصليح للجزيره قال قائد قوات الواجب
القطريه في مهمه المغرب خالد الحميدي ان
جهود الانقاذ التي
يسهم فيها الفريق القطري ستستمر للبحث عن
ناجين من الزلزال واكد الحميدي ان الفرق
واجهت صعوبات في عمليات الانقاذ بسبب
انسداد الطرق
فيستمر بشكل عام في راح يستمر الفريق في
عمليات البحث
وكل شيء بيد الله ان شاء الله سواء بعد
خمس ايام او سته ايام وسبع ايام احتمال
وجود الاحياء يعني كل شيء مقدم عند رب
العالمين بعض المناطق هناك تكون على سبوح
الجبال وصعوبه هطول المعدات الثقيل هذا
يشكل العار كبير بالنسبه حق
الاستماريه العمل في هذه المناطق خاصه
انها تكون قرى صغيره وتكون على شبه جبل
وجميع الطرق الماديه امام هذا الاسبوع
سقوط الاحجار من من الجبال ادى الى انسداد
الطرق
وهذه تفاصيل اكثر نذهب الى عثمان فرح
والجوله مع مراسلينا على الارض هناك اذا
عثمان ليلى رضيعه يبيتها المنكوبون بهذا
الزلزال
نعم يبيتون في العراء كثيرون ما زالوا
قلقين غير مطمئنين
للعوده الى منازلهم ما زالت لديهم مخاوفهم
عانوه كثير كان هناك هول الصدمه التي لم
يتغلبوا عليها فقط هم ليسوا مطمئنين بعد
كما قلت بالتالي هناك اولويه لاواء هؤلاء
وبالفعل هناك يعني تم توفير خيم
للاواء المؤقت ولكن حتى الان هي غير كافيه
خاصه مع تغير حاله الطقس الى الابرد في
المستقبل القريب هناك في اقليم الحوز
تحديدا عند سفوح جبال الاطلس حيث كان
الاثر الاكبر لهذا الزلزال وفي ذات الوقت
تستمر جهود الانقاذ والاولويه لدى فرق
الانقاذ هي الوصول الى ناجين او نقل جرحى
الى حيث يحتاجون العلاج ومن ثم ايضا
انتشاء انتشال المزيد من الجثث اذا ما
كانت موجوده الحصيله حتى بلغت
291 ما زالت مستمره للوصول الى المناطق
النائيه المناطق المعزوله ويعيق ذلك تراكم
الصخور والانهيارات الجبليه في الطرق في
تلك المناطق عموما معنا من مراكش عمر
الحاج في هذه الجوله ومن ورزازات سيف
الدين بوعللاق ابدا منك عمر تزوجت في عديد
من المناطق وكما قلت يبدو ان هناك يعني ما
زال القلق موجودا لدى الناس هم غير قادرين
على العوده الى منازلهم تلك التي تبدو
وكانها ايله للسقوط والبعض حتى وان لم تكن
ايل للسقوط بسبب الصدمه ما زالوا قلقين
هذا صحيح عثمان اما بالنسبه لمن فقد منزله
وفقد افرادا من عائلته فان البقاء في
العراء وفي الخيم التي قدمتها السلطات
والمتطوعين هو امر اجباري لا خيار له فيه
اما هنا في مراكش على الاقل حيث نقف في
احد المنتزهات فان لهؤلاء ربما بعض الخيره
في البقاء خارج المنزل تدفعه يدفعهم الخوف
من الصدمه كما ذكرت التي لما يستوعبوها
بعد ولكن تبقى لديهم بعض البيوت على عكس
الطائفه الاخرى او الفئه الاخرى التي
ذكرناها كما تشاهد الاهالي الكثير منهم ما
يزال يفضل البقاء في الخارج وكما تشاهد
الرياح وتشعر بها انت ايضا هنا في مراكش
هناك برد يعني رياح شديده وربما لا
يستطيعون كما هو الحال عندما يشتد البرد
في ساعات وقبيله الفجر يدخل الكثير منهم
مضطرا الى البيوت صغار كما تشاهد ونساء
يعني ربما يفضلون تحمل هذا البرد على ان
يصابوا باذى وهم لا يعلمون حتى الان ولا
احد يعلم بطبيعه الحال ان كانت هذه الهزه
او هزات رداديه كبيره ستعود مره اخرى ولكن
كما ذكرت وتجول الزملاء في مختلف المناطق
المنكوبه وان الخيم تقدم لهؤلاء الاولويه
لهؤلاء حقيقه
ايضا العمل كنا نتحدث في مداخلات سابقه عن
وجود نوع من المنظومه الان في تنسيق
المساعدات في توزيع
الثياب وايضا الاغطيه والطعام للمتضررين
وايضا في ارسال الفرق لم يعد الامر قائما
على المبادره هناك تنظيم مع مرور ربما
ربما نعم هناك مساعدات تصل حتى عن الافراد
تصل الى المتضررين في مراكش ولكن مراكش
ربما يعني الضرر كان فيها اقل اذا ما
استثنينا احياء قديمه واستثنينا ايضا
المدينه القديمه في مراكش ولكن الضرر كان
فيها اقل وبالتالي تصل المساعدات الى
هؤلاء والقيم ولكن تدفق المساعدات الاكبر
ربما في المناطق الاكثر تضررا من مناطق
انت زرتها في اقليم الحوز في ام زميز مثلا
او او في شجاء وحيث كنت قبل قليل
هذا صحيح هذا صحيح عثمان الاولويه لهؤلاء
بشكل قاطع ما تزال السيارات في مختلف
الاحجام
والشاحنات تتقاطر تتقاطر الى تلك المنطقه
تسبب لنا بعض المشاكل الحقيقه في
التنقل لانها تغلق الطرقات ونحن شاهدت في
مداخلاتي سابقه الطريق ضيق جدا ولكن هذا
يعود مره اخرى لهذه الهبه هذه اليقظه هذه
هذا التضامن الحقيقي الذي اصبح مضربا
المثل لابناء الشعب المغربي بمناسبه
التقينا بالمناس جاءوا من المحافظات بعيده
من الولايات بعيده من فاس من من طنجه الى
القمر لان لانه
بالفعل هناك حاجه حاجه حقيقيه عثمان
كل من اصيب وهذا نعم
نعم قلت هب وبالفعل يعني قد انتقل الان
الى سيف الدين بوعلاق موجود في ورزازات
وعمر قال هبوا ما يحدث بالفعل هو هبه هب
شعبيه وما يحدث في ورزازات هو مثال فقط
على ذلك على ذلك يعني على سبيل المثال
وليس الحصر
نعم نعم عثمان حقيقه هو درس حقيقي في
الانسانيه درس نراه كل دقيقه وكل ساعه في
ورزازات ورزازات التي فقدت اكثر من اربعين
شخصا من ابنائها فقدت او اصيب فيها
العشرات من المواطنين ايضا
المئات من المتاجر التي تضررت بشكل كبير
او بشكل حتى تلك التي تضررت بشكل جزئي لم
تعد صالحه للاقامه وبالتالي بات العراء
وباتت الخيام هي الماوى لهؤلاء ولكن عثمان
في المحن تيبرز معدن الناس هنا في ورزازات
مثلا اهب شعبيه حقيقيه لاحظ معي هذه عينه
عينه صغيره عينه صغيره من المبادره
الشعبيه التي اطلقت من منظمات مجتمع مدني
من مواطنين والشبان
منذ اللحظات الاولى منذ اللحظات الاولى
للزلزال بداوا في جمع المواد الغذائيه
وايضا في المياه وفي الملابس الجاهزه وفي
الاغغطيه هم يقومون مثل ما تلاحظ الان
بفرز ما وصلهم من هبات ومساعدات من
الملابس ويتم تقسيمها طبعا حسب الجنس وحسب
الفئه العمريه سوف نتحدث لو سمحت لي عثمان
ساتحدث مع احدى الشابات التي ساهمت منذ
الدقائق والساعات الاولى للزلزال في
التطوع من اجل خلق حاله ودينامكيه لتجميع
المساعدات وايصالها الى محتاجها مريم لو
تحدثين كيف انطلقت هذه المبادره
بالمركز ديال المركز للاستقبال المساعدات
من اجل العائلات والاسر التي تضررت في
خلال هذا الزلزال اللي وقع في البلاد
ديالنا حنا يعني كجمعيات الشباب الايجابي
يعني انطلقت العمليه منذ ساعات الاولى بعد
الزلزال واللي حاولنا اننا نختاروا واحد
المركز
المجموعه ديال المساعدات من طرف اشخاص من
طرف منظمه اخرى من طرف جمعيات اخرين
يجيبو لهاد المجموعه ديال المساعدات من
طبيعه الحال اللي غادي نقدموها واللي
كنقدموها من خلال هذه الايام كامله بعد
تجميع المساعدات مريم كيف تقيمون
الاحتجاجات في القرى والدواوير والتجمعات
السكانيه في مختلف مناطق لحدود
الساعه جات كثيره خلال الزيارات التفاديه
اللي قمنا بها كشباب ديال الجمعيه كاين
احتياجات في الاغطيه احتياجات في الخيام
خصوصا الخيام حيتاش الناس كتبات في العراء
الملابس ولكن ما كاينش
ديالهم بزاف يعني المنزل دياله ما بقاش
كاع نهائيا وبالتالي كيبات في العراء يعني
الحدود الساعه كاين كاين في الخيام واللي
على الاسف حنا كنحاولو اننا
ومع الناس مع جمعيات وحدين اخرين انا
نحاولو نجمعو هاد الخيام هادي ونوصلوها
لهاد الناس اللي محتاجين كيف تقيمون الهبه
الشعبيه التي قام بها مواطنوا ومتسك منطقه
ورزازات التي على الاقل نتحدث عن قلب
المدينه التي لم تتضرر من الزلزال
هذه عمليه ولا هادشي اللي كنشوفوه الان شي
حاجه اللي تثلج في الصدر بحيث ما كناش
كنتظروا هذا الكم الهائل ديال المساعدات
ما كناش كنتظروا ان نستقبلوا هذا الناس
بحيث اليوم الاول كنا غير شكرا وصلت
الفكره اللي وقفتها وتصبحين لمريم شكرا
شكرا جزيلا لك بالتوفيق في هذه الهبه
الشعبيه الاستثنائيه المغاربه حقيقه عثمان
يقدمون درسا حقيقيا لبقيه الشعوب العالم
ربما لم ارى مثل هذه
اللحمه الوطنيه التي تشكلت من عمق
الزلزال من الهزات الارتدائيه اهتز الشعب
المغربي الى مساعده
والنجده من اتضرر من الزلزال عثمان نعم
كما يقال هذا شيء يثلج الصدر وسوف يسجل في
تاريخ وانت شاهد عيان عليه في ورزازات على
سبيل المثال السيف وننتقل الى تحناوت في
اقليم الحوز هذه هي القريه في سفوح جبل
الاطلس من القرى التي تضررت كثيرا المختار
العلاوي معنا من هناك كيف تصف المشهد
المختار
نام عثمان لربما ان العامل الحاسمه الذي
سيكون هنا خلال الفتره القادمه سيكون هو
المناخ لماذا المناخ لان هذه المناطق
قريبه من سلسله جبال الاطلس وتعرف درجات
حراره
منخفضه جدا وقد بدات هذه الحراره في
الانخفاض خلال يوم امس قال لي شهود عيان
ان درجه الحراره بلغت ثلاثه واربعه درجات
اربع درجات في الليل
وخلال الايام القادمه سيكون الحال ابرد
بالاضافه الى هذا هناك توقعات بان تشهد
هذه المناطق تساقطات مطريه خلال الفتره
القادمه وهذه التساقطات المطريه ستنعكس
على مستويين المستوى الاول هو انها ستؤثر
على البنايات والمنازل الاله للسقوط وقد
تتسبب في سقوط بعض تلك المنازل اذا قدر
الله
العامل الثاني وهو انها ستؤثر على هذه
الخيام هذه الخيام في هذه المنطقه على
سبيل المثال تحناوت اقامتها السلطات
المغربيه من اجل ايواء اولئك الذين خسروا
منازلهم واصبحوا في العراق هذه هذه الخيام
موجوده هنا موجوده في بعض المناطق
وبالتالي فهي تاوي عدد من هؤلاء الذين
فقدوا منازلهم لكن التحدي ايضا وان هذه
الخيام خلال الايام القادمه اذا كانت هناك
تساقطات مطريه واذا كانت هناك تساقطات
ثلجيه فانها فان المعاناه ستتضاعف من اجل
معرفه كيف سيعيش هؤلاء هذه المرحله
والايام الخادمه معنا فتيحه فتيحه اولا
البرد في هذه المنطقه
هذه الايام
الله يرحم لكم الوالدين والضوء والمراحيض
واسمعوا
ما عندناش ديال الشريبه الحمد لله باش
غنديروا
الله يرحم لكم الوالدين بغينا علما
راه قاسح ولقينا
[موسيقى]
المشكل دابا الدراري الصغار والناس
فتيحه في الايام العاديه وانتم في المنازل
قبل الزلزال كيف كنتم يعني تواجهون البرد
البرد قاسح قاسح فكانغطاو اربعه
من من البرد
قاصح بالزاف ودبا اللي كان طالبو الله
بغينا الطواليطات وبغينا
نضاربه بغينا سميتوا الناس
شكرا لك فتيحه على هذه المعطيات وهذه
الصوره اذن هذا هو المشهد هنا عثمان في
الوقت الذي ايضا تتواصل فيه وصول
المساعدات سواء المساعدات الرسميه او
المساعدات التي يقدمها المحسنين وايضا
الجمعيات جمعيات المجتمع المدني
نعم وحتى الافراد كما نشاهد بهذه القوافل
التي تستمر في الاتجاه الى المناطق
المتضرره من تحناوت في اقليم الحوز
المختار العملاوي شكرا لك شكرا سيف الدين
وعمر الحاجه في مراكش
وعوده الى حسن جمول تفضل شكرا لك فرح
وشكرا لشبكه مراسلينا المنتشرين في
المناطق
المنكوبه
زلزال المغرب شكرا لكم
رافق فريق من قناه الجزيره الانجليزيه
فرقه اغاثه تابعه للقوات الملكيه المغربيه
تواجهت جوا الى قريه سلاتني يعقوب بجبال
الاطلس لتقديم المساعدات لضاحيه الزلزال
الذي ضرب المنطقه الجمعه الماضيه
بمجرد ان ارتقت المروحيه التي تقلنا نحو
الاعالي وبدا قائدها يناور بحذر بين
الاخاديد العميقه التي نحتت ممرات بين
جبال الاطلس حتى بدات اثار الزلزال القوي
تلوح لنا الرحله محفوفه بالمخاطر والرياح
هنا قويه للغايه القرى تلممم جرحها
والتمار يترك اثاره بارزه للعيان اعطى
قائد المروحيه الاشاره لبدء عمليه الانزال
الجوي
بمساعده اهالي القرى المعزوله على قمم
جبال الاطلس
قبطانه عمليه الانزال الجوي للمساعدات
الانسانيه ونحن الان نعمل في الوصول الى
قلب بعض القرى التي انهارت
كليا او جزئيا جراء زلزال والهزات
الارتداديه
وصلنا ثلاثاء يعقوب احدى القرى الاكثر
تضررا من الزلزال فرق الاغاثه التابعه
للجيش تسابق الزمن املا في البحث عن ناجين
تحت الانقاض فرص العثور على احياء تتطاءل
مع مرور الوقت
بشر نبي
ادخال جميع الفرق التدخل للبحث عن الضحايا
بطرق التقنيه والامنيه للضحيه كذلك
وللمتدخلين
وبعد ذلك نعتمد كذلك على البحث الكلاب
الكلاب التي ترشدنا الى مكان وجود الضحايا
سيبدا الناجون رحله علاج قد تطول فاطمه
ايت احمد تخارب دموعها وهي تتذكر ما حدث
خلال الليله التي ارتجت فيها الارض
وصل الجرح الى القاعده العسكريه في مراكش
يبدو العقيد اسماعيل العلوي قلقا بشان
حاله هذا النجم من تحت الانقاض
يبدو انه يعاني من متلازمه الهاس وسيخضع
على وجه السرعه لتحاليل شامله وقد يحتاج
لغسيل كولا هذه هي غرفه العمليات التي
تباشر عمل الاغاثه صور حيه من مسيرات
تابعه للجيش تحدد الاماكن التي تحتاج
تدخلا عاجلا يشرح لي عميدان في الجيش
تفاصيل عمليه تشارك فيها جهات متعدده
وتقتضي تنسيقا واسعا للتغلب على صعوبه
تضاريس المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اصيب من صوت الناني بجراح بعد تعرض
سياراتهم لاطلاق نار بينما كانت على
الشارع الرئيسي في بلده حواره جنوب مدينه
نابلس بالضفه الغربيه وقال متحدث باسم
الاسعاف الاسرائيليين المستوطنين اصيبا من
شظايا زجاج نوافذ السياره التي تعرضت
لاطلاق النار واكدت اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان التحقيقات الاوليه تشير الى
ان مسلحا او اكثر اطلقوا النيران على
سيارتهم ولذوا بالفرار ووصلت تعزيزات
عسكريه كبيره للمنطقه واغلقت الشارع
الرئيسي ومدخل مدينه نابلس وبشرت عمليه
تمشيط بحثا عن المهاجمين وقال الناطق باسم
حماسنا العمليه هي رد بطولي على اجراءات
الوزير الاسرائيلي المتطرف اتمار بحق
الاسرى ومخططات المستوطنين ضد الاقصى
اعلنا الاتحاد المغربي لكره القدم التبرع
بايرادات مباراه منتخب اسود الاطلس امام
منتخب بوركينا فاسو لصالح ضاحيه الزلزال
الذي ضرب البلاد واكد الاتحاد ان عائدات
المباراه ستذهب للصندوق الخاص بطلق
المساهمات التطوعيه التضامنيه لتدبير
الاثار المترتبه عن الزلزال كما اعلن لاعب
المنتخب المغربي لكره القدم عن تبرعهم
بجميع منح المباريات المقبله الى غايه كاس
امم افريقيا المقرره مطلع العام المقبل
وذلك لفائده ضحايا زلزال الحوز
قرر الاتحاد الاوروبي لكره القدم الوقوف
دقيقه صمت قبل مباريات الانديه والمنتخبات
حتى نهايه الاسبوع المقبل حدادا على ضحايا
زلزال المغرب وفيضانات ليبيا واعلن
اليهوديه
تقديم كامل الدعم للاتحاد الليبي بعد مصرع
عدد من اللاعبين في الفيضانات التي ضربت
عددا من المدن الليبيه
مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
واليكم ابرز العناو
سيول ليبيا تغمر خرى باكملها في الشرق
وتمح ربع مدينه درنه والحصيله مصرع اكثر
من
5300 واستمرار عمليات البحث والانقاذ عن
الاف في عداد المفقودين
وفي المغرب عمليات البحث والانقاذ تتواصل
بحثا عن ناجين من زلزال الحوز اليونيسف
تقول ان حول مئه الف طفل تاثروا بالزلزال
والعاهل المغربي يزور المصابين في مستشفى
مراكش
اصابه مستوطنين باطلاق نار في بلده حوار
جنوبي نابلس قوات الاحتلال تمشي طول منطقه
بحثا عن منفذ العمليه بعد فراره وحماس تصف
العمليه بالرد على ممارسات الاحتلال بحق
الاسرى والمسجد الاقصى
اذا نواصل تعطيتنا والبدايه مع تطورات
السيول في درنه الليبيه
[موسيقى]
اذا قتل الالاف ولا يزال الافنا اخرون في
عداد المفقودين جراء سيول التي ضربت مدن
في الشرق الليبيه وكانت الحصيله الاكبر في
مدينه درنه فقد قالت وكاله الانباء
الليبيه ان عدد القتلى تجاوز خمسه الاف
بينما يقدر عدد المفقودين بالالاف كما قال
مسؤول بالاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات الصليب
الاحمر والهلال الاحمر ان نحو عشره الاف
شخص في عداد المفقودين بعد سيول
والفيضانات العارمه
هذا واظهر مقطع فيديو بثته منصه محليه في
مدينه درنه انتشار عدد كبير من الجثث في
منطقه شيحه بالمدينه في انتظار التعرف على
هويتها كما بثت السكان وناشطون مناشدات من
داخل مقبره المدينه لارسال اليه حفر
للتمكن من دفن الجثث
واظهرت مشاهد جويه حصلت عليها الجزيره
اثار دمار هائل لاحياء باكملها في مدينه
درنا الليبيه سببتها السيول وتظهر المشاهد
دمار العديد من المنازل والممتلكات
والمنشات في المدينه الساحليه وغيبت
السيول احياء كامله في المدينه
من جهه وصف هشام بوشكيوات وزير الطيران
المدني في الحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان
وعضو لجنه الطوارئ في مدينه درنه وصف
الوضع بالخطير والكارثي وفي مقابله مع
الجزيره قال
نظرنا اصبحت غير صالحه للسكن وان الجثث
منتشره في كل مكان
حقيقه كارثي عادل الضحايا يزيد كل دقيقه
ان العدد سوف يتجاوز 2000 2500
ضحيه هرعت فرق الانقاذ وفرق الجيش للمنطقه
دارنا المنكوبه منذ فجر امس وما زالت
تتعامل مع الوضع في عمليه الانقاذ وانتشار
الجثث الليبيين تناسب مشاكلهم وتناسب
الانقسام اللي موجود وهبوا بكل حد وصوب من
اربد بلاد ومن شرقها لمساعده اخوانهم في
مدينه درنه لان عدد المفقودين كبير شوي
يعني
اكثر من 24 ساعه يعني صعب انه يكون
احياء يعني الجزء المحيط بالمنطقه
المنكوبه التي هي جربها
الفيضان اخليت تماما
وسيطرت عليها القوات
الجيش
وخاصه مربعات تتعامل معها في عمليه اخلاء
الجثث ولكن اعتقد المدينه غير صالحه للسكن
الان
قال رئيس حكومه الوحدات الوطنيه عبد
الحميد دبيبه ان ليبيا بحاجه الى معدات
متطوره تمكن فرق البحث من الوصول الى
الضحايا الذين جرفتهم السيول الى البحر
عندنا عدد كبير من الجسد في البحر لان
الوادي هو محدش يريد
ما كل التوابع البشريه ولا حتى الامارات
انت عامل اني اقول لك لحد الان الامور
اليوم قاعد وتحت السيطره ويشوفوا ويخدموا
يوم نحتاجه الى اي اجهزه الاجهزه هي مرات
هل نطلبها بدون اي
حزمه ولا بنستعمله ولا بدون مواربه نحن
نطلب الدعم مش لاجل الدعم يطلب الاجل في
الدعم
لامور اللي هو محتاجينها فقط
واكدت بيبه ان اكثر من 400 سياره اسعاف
تمكنت من دخول مدينه درنه للمساعده في
عمليات اجلاء المصابين والضحايا وارتدا في
مقابلات مع الجزيره ان فرق الانتشار
البحري الليبيه بدات العمل في البحث عن
جثث الضحايا في البحر
[موسيقى]
من البحر وهذا
قاعدين حتى البحريه الليبيه وبعض الغواثين
وبعض الضفادع البشريه قاعدين يحاولوا بكل
جهد في الجدد عمليه البحث الجنائي داير
الدوله كيف ما قلنا والامور ملناش مرتاحين
ولكن بعون الله
نجتاز هذه المرحله
معنا من طرابلس مراسله الجزيره احمد خليفه
احمد ماذا يصلكم من معلومات عن الوضع في
دارنا في هذا الوقت
هناك تحدي جديد امام فرق الانقاذ حسن في
مدينه درنه هذا التحدي يتمثل في عدم وجود
اكياس كافيه
لجمع الجثث او الاكياس التي تغلف تغلف
فيها الجثث او تغلف الجثث عفوا يبدو ان
هناك نقص في هذه الاكياس منذ قليل استمعت
الى مطالبات من هناك من احد افراد فرق
الانقاذ يطالب فيها بتوفير هذه الاكياس
لوضع الجثث التي يعثر عليها في اثناء
عمليات البحث عن الجثث ايضا اليوم لفظت
مياه البحر عددا من الجثث في الساحل
الشرقي لمدينه درنه وايضا في ساحلها
الغربيه هذه الجثث
طبعا
لفظها او نقلتها السيول عندما
هاجمت المناطق السكنيه في مدينه درنه دفعت
عددا كبيرا من الجثث وعندما انهارت البيوت
هناك شتت بقيت تحت
الانهيار الانهيارات او تحت الركام وهناك
جثث دفعتها السيول الى البحر اليوم البحر
لفظ عددا من هذه الجثث جمعتها فرق البحث
عن الجثث في مدينه ادرنان ايضا هناك
مجهودات
لفني الكهرباء حيث عادت الكهرباء بشكل
تدريجي لمدينه درنه وايضا الاتصالات عادت
بشكل طفيف جدا لم تعد كما كانت في السابق
باعتبار ان
السيول والفيضانات التي حدثت يمكن القول
انها نسفت معها ابراج لشركات الاتصالات
وبالتالي هناك صعوبه على الاقل في هذه
الايام
على الابراج الى امكينتها التي كانت فيها
ولكن تحاول الفرق الفنيه من العاصمه
طرابلس ومن مدينه بنغازي ومن مدينه درنه
تحاول اصلاح ما يمكن اصلاحه في قطاع
الاتصالات على الاقل حتى يطمئن الناس على
بعضهم البعض هناك الكثير من الاسر من
مدينه درنه وهناك الكثير من العائلات تقطن
في مناطق اخرى خارج مدينه درنه حاليا
الاتصال مقطوع بينها وبين ذويها واحبابها
في مدينه درنه ايضا اليوم اكد لنا نائب
رئيس المجلس البلدي في مدينه درنه ان هناك
700 جثمان انتشلت بين الامس بين رايه
البارحه واليوم لم يتم التعرف الى اصحابها
حتى الان وهذا يقود الى الاعتقاد بان هذه
الجثث اصحابها من المبلغ عنهم من
المفقودين حيث هناك اسر نجت من هذه السيول
وابلغت الجهات المختصه في مدينه درنه
واطلقت نداءات للبحث عن مفقودها في هذه
الاسر ايضا حجم الخسائر الان المجهودات في
مدينه درنه تتجه كلها الى حصر الخسائر
البشريه حصر الخسائر الماديه البحث عن
الجثث
حيث توجد ما زالت توجد العشرات ويمكن
القول قد توجد المئات من هذه الجثث تحت
الركام وايضا تحت الطمي الذي تكونا في
المدينه بسبب اختلاط الطين والرمل بكميات
الكبيره من الامطار وكميات الكبيره من
مياه السهول السيول التي تدفقت الى
الاحياء السكنيه في المدينه ومساحتها من
على وجه الارض ماذا عن عمليات
المساعدات تجميع المساعدات
وارسالها من من طرابلس والمحيط والمناطق
الغربيه الى درنه والمناطق الاخرى
المنكوبه في الشرق
بالنسبه
للمساعدات حسن هناك المساعدات المحليه
وهناك مساعدات دوليه اليوم على سبيل
المثال اعلنت الخارجيه القطريه ان هذه
الليله ستصل اول طائره قطريه الى مطار
بنينا في مدينه بنغازي هذه الطائره ستكون
محمله
بالمساعدات كالاغذيه والادويه ومواد
الاغاثه هذا ما لنا الناطق باسم الخارجيه
القطريه في وقت سابق اليوم ايضا تونس
اليوم اعلنت عن تسير رحلات من المساعدات
والدعم من مطار العوينه في مطار عسكري
العوينه في تونس او معسكر او قاعده
العوينه باتجاه شرق ليبيا ايضا الجزائر
كانت هناك ايضا معلومات وصلتنا من زملائنا
في الجزائر ان الرئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد
تبون وجه
ان يكون هناك جسر جوي ما بين الجزائر وما
بين شرق ليبيا بتسير ثمان طائرات عسكريه
ايضا في المقابل مصر اليوم وصل رئيس
الاركان رئيس اركان الجيش المصري ومعه
اطباء وبصره معه طائرتان ثلاث طائرات
احداه يستقلها هو ومعه عدد من الاطباء
والطائرتان الاخريان محملتان
بالمواد الاغاثيه والدوائيه والمساعدات
والدعم ايضا تركيا تركيا وصل في وقت سابق
اليوم صباحا
فريق تركي
متخصص من الاطباء ومن فرق البحث
يقدر عددهم تقريبا ب168 شخصا من منظمه
افاد التركيه للبحث عن
الجثث وانتشال الجثث وتقديم المساعدات
وهناك ايضا مستشفى ميداني مع الفريق
التركي وايضا هناك مستشفى م سيكون مع
الفريق القطري فهذه كلها مساعدات هذا عدا
عن المساعدات التي تنطلق من المدن الليبيه
وبالمناسبه حسن هذه الازمه او هذه الكارثه
وحدت الليبيين بشكل كبير جدا الامر يمكن
القول انه يدعو للدهشه حقيقه على الرغم من
اختلافات الليبيين الفكريه وايضا ما حدث
من انقسام من السنوات الاخيره لكن هذه
الكارثه الجميع هبه هبه رجل واحد من الشرق
والغرب والجنوب والوجهه للجميع هي مدينه
درنه شكرا لك احمد خليفه احدثتنا من
طرابلس
ومن مدينه البيضاء في شرق ليبيا معنا عبد
الرحيم مازق مدير مركز البيضاء الطبي وهو
المستشفى الحكوميه الرئيسيه في المدينه
سيد عبد الرحيم مع هذا العدد الهائل من
الضحايا ومن الجرحى كيفيه يتم التعامل مع
هذا الواقع الصحي
بوجود مستشفيات يعني تكون محدوده العدد
وفي بعض الاحيان محدوده الامكانيات
نعم اخي الكريم
هو حقيقه للاسف العدد جل هو حالات وفاه لا
يوجد جرح اطلاقا
كانت صاعقه فعلا كانت كارثه اذهلت جميع
قوم جميع من تعرض لهذا السيول توفاهم الله
لا توجد اصابات لا توجد اي
اضرار بسيطه او كل الاسرار كانت بالغه
البيوت جرف الاحياء وجميع مواطنين الذين
تقع بيوتهم في في مسار هذه السيول للاسف
توفاهم الله هناك عائلات كامله احياء
كامله
على وجه الارض للاسف كارثه حقيقيه اذهلت
جميع في في اثارها التي كانت لدرجه غير
متوقعه للاسف لا يوجد شرحه معظم الجرح
اعداد بسيطه من فرق الان نتيجه محاولتهم
انتشار
[موسيقى]
الجثثهم تعرضوا لاصابات لكن للاسف الشيء
المحزن المحزن فعلا وان كل من يتم اخراجه
تكون جتهادا
اذا يعني هذا هذا يدعون الى الاستنتاج بان
من يحكى انهم مصابون قد يكونوا ايضا في
عداد الضحايا كما هو الحال ربما لا نتمنى
ذلك ولكن ربما يكون الحال ايضا مع
المفقودين
نعم للاسف هذا ما نشاه فعلا النجوم
المفقودين الى الان مره ثمانيه واربعين
ساعه عليهم
ان معظم مطلوبين هناك جثث تدخل الان على
سطح البحر هناك في الاوديه الجنوبيه مناطق
جنوبيه لمناطق جبل الاخضر جثه بدات تظهر
شيئا بعد الانصار المياه للاسف جميع
المفقودين كل من يتم البلاغ عنه المفقود
تظهر جساته للاسف قد توفاه الله للاسف
بشيء يعجز عن الوصل يعجز الوصف عليه
وفد هذه الحادثه فعلا اعداد كبيره جدا
اعداد كبيره جدا مدينه درنه اليوم احياء
كامله ظهرت تحت الماء احياء كامله منصحه
ونقلت في مجلس نقلت الى عرض البحر للاسف
لا توجد لها اثر اطلاقا مباني كامله لا
يوجد لها اثر كذلك مدينه سوسه غطوه المياه
الساحليه
وتحت حتى حتى القبور والرفاس الخرافات
المدفولين في هذه المقبره منذ اعوام ظهرت
على وجه الارض من يهدد بالكارثه فعلا بايه
نتيجه تحلل هذه الجسديل وضع الماساوي جدا
جدا جدا يحتاج الى تدخل طويل وعاجل للتدخل
دولي من اصل من ازمه الشال هذه الجذف
ومعالج جميع الاضرار طيب
في القطاع الطبي في القطاع الصحي الذي
انتم جزء منه
كما هو معلوم هل لنا ان نسمع منك اهم
المشاكل او التحديات الان التي تواجه هذا
القطاع
ولافت يعني ما قلته انه ليس هناك
مصابون بل الجميع في عداد اما ضحايا او
مفقودين مع العلم ان الارقام شبه الرسميه
التي تصدر تتحدث عن عن
مصابين
ويقدرون بالالاف
للاسف اخي الكريم
سواء داخل مدينه درنه او سوسه او
منطقه عمر المختار جنوب جبل الاخضر او
مدينه البيضاء الرئيسيه او مدينه الشحات
التي ضربها هذه السنون
المصابين اعدادتهم لا تصل لا تصل لهذه
الاعداد يعني لا لكن لم تفك المئات يجلها
المصابين يعني
الارض سواء طبيه او فرق الدعم اللوجستي
اما الباقي في اعداد كبيره جدا جدا
سيكون الرقم مبدع من داخل مدينه من يتوقع
احد الاعداد في التقديرات اوليه
يتجاوز العدد 20 الف
متر ارقام خياليه جدا للاسف حتى الخدمه
الطبيه
تقف عاجزا في ظل
وجود امكانيات ضرب السيول للمستشفيات
مدينه
البيضاء كونها اكبر مدينه في مناطق الجبل
الاخضر بعد شبيهه مدينه درنه ضربت حتى
المستشفيات واتلفت الاجهزه واكلفت جميع
الامكانيه اخلاء المستشفيات من المرضى من
المناطق مرتفعه للاسف
[موسيقى]
جبل الاخضر تامين الموقع الكارثه للاسف
عبد الرحيم مازق مدير مركز البيضاء الطبيه
من مدينه البيضاء في شرق ليبيا شكرا جزيلا
لك
وللحديث
عن ايضا هذه
الكارثه
وما يجري
اضافه الى المساعدات التي بدات تصل ايضا
الى مناطق شرق ليبيا معنا من مدينه الابرق
غرب درنه جلال المهشش المتحدث باسم مطار
الابرق لو نعرف منك
سيد جلال
ما الذي وصل حتى الان من مساعدات ممن وما
هي نوعيتها حتى اللحظه
السلام عليكم اخوي اول حاجه نحن المساعدات
المساعدات وصلت من جميع الدول العربيه
يعتبر حاليا الجزائر ومصر وصلا قوافل
الطبيه ومن فرق الانقاذ لنحييهم من هذا من
هذا المنصه وبارك الله فيهم نحن هنا عندنا
القياده تابعت في في فرق انقاذ وفي اضافات
بشريه نزلنا عندنا في المطار الابرقوا الى
درنه ونحن في طبعا نحن نستقبله في الرحلات
على مدى 24 ساعه او ما زال فيه قوافل اخرى
نحن قاعدين نستنوا ممكن الليله ممكن في
الصبح فنحن نرحب باي اغاثه
او اجنبيه يعني من ذكرتهم
قد وصلوا الى مطار الابرق في حين ان
عديد من الدول الاخرى ارسلت الى مطارات
اخرى ايضا في منطقه الشرق
نعم نعم نعم نحن وصلت الى مطار الابرق من
الجزائر ومن مصر قوافل انسانيه اغاثه على
عناصر طبيه على فرق انقاذ وفيه طبعا مطار
طبرق حتى هو استقبل ولكننا نحكي لك
اليوم تقريبا ما يقارب عشرين طائره ربطه
في مطار الابره ما بين اسعاف قارئ ما بين
الشاحنات محمله بالادويه
وما زلت مستمر ما زال الامداد مستمر
ما الذي يريدكم الان من معلومات يعني انت
لست بعيدا كثيرا على ما يبدو عن دارنا
والمعلومات تصلكم ايضا اولا باول ما هي
المعلومات التي نعم الم
علومات سي
ئات ابناء المعلومات اللي وصلت
طاقه 15 الف وما زالوا فيه ضحايا ما زالوا
مفقودين وما زالوا تحت الانقاذ وفي ناس
مازال مصدوم الى الان يعني وضع كاري في
دارنا صراحه وفي منطقه المخيلي وفي منطقه
سوسه يعني وضع حجاب الاخضر وضع ساردي جدا
يعني التقديرات التي بدات تمهد لاعداد
الخمسه عشر الف والعشرين الف ضحيه
يبدو انها يعني اقرب الى الواقع او ربما
تتحقق
نعم 20
انا قالت تبحث على اهاليها ما زالوا
يبحثوا على اهاليهم ما زال اهاليهم اللي
هم
حتى سكن حتى سكن
اشرت الى ان المطار سيبقى مستعدا لاستقبال
المزيد من المساعدات وهناك مساعدات اخرى
متوقعه
ومجدوله
ماذا في هذه المساعدات ومتى يمكن ان تصل
ومن اين
حاليا توزيع في المطار والمطار مستعد
بكافه الاجهزه متواجده على مدى 24 ساعه
ولكن عندنا المعلومات مازالا اكيده على
الدول اللي حتبعثتها هي يقولوا ان في
الامارات في من دول شقيقه اخرى ولكن نحن
ما نقدرش ناكده الحاجه اللي تطلع على
الارض اللي وصلت على الارض توه من دول مصر
والجزائر وعندنا من اخوتنا من طرابلس ومن
مصراتها الناس بحثت عناصر طبيه وبحثة
ادويه
واغاثه بجميع انواعها لكن نحن ما نقدرش
نحكوا الا على الارض حاليا مازلنا نعم
اشرت الى مساعدات
وصلت من طرابلس من مصراته ومن اماكن اخرى
في الداخل الليبي وصلت الى المطار
نعم نعم في في مساعدات وصلا من من
الغرب طبيه وعندنا من هنا من عند بنغازي
طبيه كذلك وارسلت الناس فرق انقاذ وارسلت
اغساء على اشكالها الحمد لله الناس مش
مقصره ولكن الحاله هي ميكانيكيه خارج
السيطره
جلال المهششه المتحدث باسم مطار الابرق
غرب درنه شكرا جزيلا لك
ساعات قليله كانت كافيه ليكتشف العالم حول
ما حدث في مدينه درنا الليبيه وبعض مدن
الشرق الليبي ولان لم تستقر بعد حصيله
ضحايا سيول والفيضانات التي اجتاحت
المدينه الا ان الظروف المناخيه وانهيار
سدين في مجرى وادي درنه شكلا ابرز عوامل
الكارثه وحصيلتها الثقيله نقترب اكثر مما
حدث هو من جغرافيا درنا وتاريخها مع
فيضانات شاهدها الوادي الذي يقسمها في هذا
التقرير
الموقع الجغرافي والظروف الطبيعيه والعامل
البشري تلتقي كلها والمحصله ما تكشف مع
الوقت من كارثه انسانيه في الشرق الليبي
لم تكن درنا الا عنوانا كبيرا لحجمها فجل
الضحايا سقط هناك داهمتهم السيول وجرفتهم
مع بيوتهم ليظل عدد الوفيات في ارتفاع
مستمر خسر اعصار دانيال الذي تحول الى
عاصفه المدينه بين سيول مجرفه من الجبل
وامواج عاتيه من البحر
جغرافيا درن مدينه جبليه تقع في شرق ليبيا
اسفل الجبل الاخضر ويحدها من الشمال البحر
الابيض المتوسط ومن الجنوب سلسله من تلال
الجبل الاخضر ويشكرها لنصفين مجرى وادي
درنه الذي يعد من اهم معالمها ومصبا لكل
السيول القديمه من جنوبها من مناطق
المخيلي والجيجا والظهر الحمر والكبه
والعزيات
وما يميز ذرنا حسب مؤرخين هو ان نصفها يقع
تحت مجرى الوادي الذي ظل مصدر خطر دائم
على السكان لتسببه في كوارث مشابهه
شاهدتها المدينه في فترات مختلفه منذ
اربعينيات القرن الماضي وعام 86 من القرن
الماضي تم بناء السدين في الوادي وشكل
مصدا وضمانه لحبس المياه المنحدره من
اعالي مناطق الجبل في العام نفسه حدث
تسريب في احد السدين عبر فتحه الصرف ما
اسفر عن حدوث فيضان اخر وفضل الوادي مره
اخرى عام 2011 وكادت المدينه ان تغرق ماذا
حدث هذه المره مع عاصفه دانيال التي ضربت
الشرق الليبي تجمعت الامطار الغزيره في
الوادي الذي يبلغ طوله 50 كيلومترا وارتفع
مستوى مياهه شكل ذلك ضغطا على السدين
المائيين اللذين يحجزان المياه في الوادي
فانهار ليجرف الطوفان الاحياء الواقعه بين
الوادي والبحر مما جعل حجم الدمرها الى
وعدد الضحاي خصوصا وسط المدينه متحدث باسم
جهاز الاسعاف الليبي قال للجزيره ان عدم
صيانه السدود في درنه كان له تاثير واضح
في حدوث الفيضانات عامل الظروف المناخيه
بدوره ساهم في مفاقمه الوضع فالمركز
الليبي للارصاد الجويه تحدث عن تسجيل
المنطقه الشرقيه مستوى مياه الامطار لم
تشهده منذ نحو 40 عاما وسجلت اكبر كميه
بالبيضاء باكثر من 400 مليمتر تصدرت مناطق
اخرى في الجبل الاخضر وذرنان نسبه طول
الامطار بشكل غير مسبوق وتجاوزت في ليله
واحده 150 ملم في منطقه قصر ليبيا ومطار
الابراج والمرج التقت السيول في الوادي
فحدثت الكارثه في درنه وتضافرت الاسباب
لتحولها الى منطقه منكوبه فقد يكون ربع
مساحتها غامرتهم مياه السيول حسب تصريحات
مسؤول ناديبيين
اعصار كبير وفيضان دمر المنطقه هذه
بالكامل يقول الشعبيه البيضاء والمدرسه
طبعا هذه كانت صيانه وشبه يعني كامله لكن
دمر الاثاث دمر العشاء الشعبيه البيضاء
هذه كلها ارزاق الناس راحت سيارتهم راحت
وطبعا العمليه متكرره سنويا
من البهايم اخذ الحيطه والحذر والله في
سياره
بعضهم ويوقفوا وقفه واحده لاخواننا في
المنطقه الشرقيه اي خدامه
باي مساله كلنا
وناسكم واليوم هم محتاجين
[موسيقى]
الان مشاهدينا الى التطورات في المغرب في
خامس ايام كارثه الزلزال
[موسيقى]
لا تزال الجهود مستمره سعيا للوصول الى
احياء تحت الركان في المناطق المتضرره من
زلزال مساء الجمعه الماضي وفي اخر
المستجدات افادت وزاره الداخليه المغربيه
بارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال الى الفين
وتسعمائه والمصابين الى
5530 هذا هو تواصل سلطات العموميه جهودها
لانقاذ واجلاء الجرحى والتكفل بالمصابين
من الضحايا وفتح الطرق التي تضررت جر
الزلزال
النظره من عليم مختلفه من هنا يتبدى حجم
الماساه ونطاقها ليس من شك في ان
الانهيارات الارضيه وتضرر الطرق تزيد من
مشقه التدخل الاغاثي حيث نظر الزلزال
دماره لكن درك الملكي المغربي وصل الى
القرى المنكوبه الوعره باعالي جبال الاطلس
تظهر الصور التي وزعها الدرك جانبا من
مهمه عناصره لتوزيع المساعدات في تلك
المناطق
يشارك اولئك العناصر ايضا في التكفل
بالمصابين العالقين هناك ويشرف على عمليات
اجلائهم جوا الى المستشفيات
ليس الى مشافي المدن الكبرى فحسب فثمت مشى
في الميدانيه انشاها الجيش المغربي لعلاج
جرح المناطق النائيه كهذا المقام في قريه
اسني باقليم الحوز المنكوب الى جنوب مراكش
تقدم هنا الرعايه الطبيه لحالات الاصابه
كافه جراء زلزال والقادمه من كل القرى
والبلدات المجاوره رماكس
[موسيقى]
يقول الجيش المغربي انه يساعد في توفير
مياه الشرب وتوزيع الاغذيه والخيام
والاغطيه على الناجين من كارثه الزلزال
اولئك الذين توزعوا على ماوي مؤقته بعد
فقدهم منازلهم بشكل كامل او جزئي
بحسبه معاناه ما الم بهم من صدمه باقين
غير بعيد عن مراكز الايواء المؤقته مواقع
تذكر بهول المصاب ما تزال فرق البحث
والانقاذ المحليه والعربيه والدوليه تحاول
الوصول الى احياء محتملين تحت الركام لا
تتاثر الجهود مع ان كلا هنا يعلم بان
منسوب الامل في العثور على ناجين اخذ في
التراجع هذه قريه انوجال او ما بقي منها
وتلك فرق مغربيه وقطريه واسبانيه تعمل على
انتشال جثامين ضحايا الزلزال من تحت
بنايات منهاره
تعززت اذا عمليات البحث ورفع الانقاض
بمشاركه فرق مختصه او فدتها الدول التي
وافق المغرب على عروض المساعده التي
قدمتها
ستجد بين اهالي اكثر المناطق قربا من مركز
الهزه الارضيه من ينتقدون بطء جهود
الانقاذ والاغاثه بعضهم في المناطق
النائيه والمعزوله يقولون انهم متروكون
لمصيرهم غير ان طبيعه التضاريس هنا
والاضرار التي لحقت بالطرق والمسالك
الجبليه لم تسهل مهمه السلطات مع بدايه
محنه الزلزال الان وقد جرى تدارك الامر
تزداد احتياجات المئات ممن شردهم زلزال
مسائل جمعه العنيف كلما طال مقامهم في
العراء او في مراكز الايواء المؤقته لن
يطول الامر تطمئن الحكومه المغربيه
ستتكفل كما قالت بعد تقييم الموقف باعاده
اعمار المناطق المنكوبه
وقال عضو البرلمان ورئيس مقاطعه مراكش
المناره عبد الواحد الشافقي انه يصعب
تحديد ارقام بشان اعداد الضحايا في الوقت
الحالي موضحا ان الصعوبات التي تعوق عمل
فرق الانقاذ تتمثل في وعوره المناطق
الجبليه التي ضربها الزلزال واكد الشافقي
في حديث للجزيره ان السلطات المحليه
مستمره في جهود الاغاثه وتقديم المساعدات
اللازمه
صعوبه كثيره خصوصا وان
المنطقه كما قلت سلفا انها منطقه جبليه
ومنطقه واعره وصعبه المسالك هذا هذا شكل
عائقا امام تقدم جهود الانقاذ في مختلف
المناطق خصوصا وان جل المسالك وجبن
الطرقات التي هي غالبها غير معبده قد
دمرها الزلزال هناك صعوبه وهناك مجهودات
من طرف الدوله ومن طرف المسؤوليه
الانقاذ بمختلف مستوياتها سواء كانت تلك
التي
تنتمي الى اجهزه الدوله او تلك التي اتت
من مناطق مختلفه من عبر العالم من
دول شقيقه وصديقه
وفي تصريح للجزيره قال قائد القوات الوجه
القطريه في مهمه المغرب خالد الحميدي ان
جهود لانقاذ التي يسهم فيها الفريق القطري
ستستمر للبحث عن ناجين من الزلزال واكد
الحميدي ان الفرق واجهت صعوبات في عمليات
الانقاذ بسبب انسداد الطرق
استمر بشكل عام في راح يستمر الفريق في
عمليات البحث
وكل شيء بيد الله ان شاء الله سواء بعد
خمسه ايام وسته ايام وسبع ايام احتمال
وجود الاحياء يعني كل شيء مقدم عند رب
العالمين بعد المناطق هناك تكون على اسبوع
الجبال وصعوبه هطول معدات الثقيل هذا يشكل
العارض كبير بالنسبه حق
الاستماريه العمل في هذه المناطق خاصه
انها تكون قرى صغيره وتكون على شبه جبل
وجميع الطرق الماديه امام هذا الاسبوع
سقوط الاحجار من من الجبال ادى الى انسداد
الطرق
معنى من تحناوت في اقليم الحوز مركز
الزلزال مراسل الجزيره المختار العلاوي
المختار
يظهر في الصوره ان
مساله الايواء تحتل الاولويه الان في هذه
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال الى جانب
عمليات الاغاثه ورفع الانقاض
نعم بالفعل حسن الايواء هو تحدي وهو
اولويه في الوقت نفسه لماذا لمجموعه من
المعطيات في اولى وبدايه تلك المعطيات
العامله الاول هو ان اقليم الحوز وهو اكبر
اقليم من حيث التدرب احتل المرتبه الاولى
من حيث عدد الاصابات والوفيات وايضا من
حيث الخسائر الماديه هذا الاقليم يمتد على
مساحه
6200 كيلومتر مربع يسكنه حسن
700 الف شخص ومن بين هات 700 الف شخص خمسه
وثمانون في المئه منهم يسكنون في الارياف
والارياف استهدفت بشكل كبير لماذا لانه
على سبيل المثال نحن الان في تحناوت
تحناوت هي بلده صغيره فيها البناء يتم وفق
المعايير الرسميه ويستخدم الناس اثناء
منازلهم الاسمنت والحديد وما الى ذلك
ولهذا كانت الاصابات والخسائر الماديه
قليله في هذه المراكز الحضاريه لكن في
الارياف حيث يسكن 85 الف
سكان اقليم الحوز هناك كانت الخسائر فادحه
لان البنايات كانت عباره عن دور طينيه
تستعمل فيها الخشب والتبن وكانت
الانهيارات كبيره خلال ساعات الصباح زرنا
بعد الدواوير والدوار هو تجمع سكاني صغير
في الريف تسكنه بعد العائلات قد يربط
بينها النسب قد تربط بينها القبيله قد
تجمعها الجغرافيه هذه الدواوير تقريبا
تقريبا كلها تعرضت للاضرار هناك بنايات او
مباني او منازل تعرضت للهدم الكلي واخرى
تعرضت للهدم الجزئي هؤلاء السكان الذين
يسكنون في هذه الدواوير الان انتقلوا الى
العراء او الخيام وبالتالي السؤال المطروح
وكيف سيقضي هؤلاء ايامهم خلال الفتره
القادمه حيث درجات الحراره ستنخفض من
المتوقع ان تكون هناك تساقطات مطريه ولهذا
يعتبر قضيه الايواء تحدي كبير خاصه وان
هؤلاء في اقليم الحوز وفي بقيه المناطق
تارودانت وفي شيشاوه وايضا في اقليم
ازيلال هؤلاء كانوا قبل ايام قليله يسكنون
في منازلهم الان يسكنون العراء كنت التقيت
ببعض الناس المتضررين هنا طرحت عليهم
السؤال التالي كيف ستقضون هل بداتم تفكرون
في المرحله القادمه البعض قال لحد الان
نحن تحت وقع الصدمه ولا نفكر ولا نفكر
البعض اتخذ حلول كما الدوله طرحت حلول
وبدات عمليا في توزيع خيام على المتضررين
في المداخله السابقه شفنا منطقه تم توزيع
فيها الخيام والناس تسكن في بعض المناطق
الناس بداوا يتعاملون مع الواقع وكما
نشاهد هنا هذه الاسره سنتعرف اكثر على
واقعها الحالي هذه الاسره على سبيل المثال
في تحناوت مركز المدينه تعرض بيتها
للاضرار واصبحت تسكن في هذا الواقع سنتعرف
فقط على شهاده قصيره من هذه السيده الان
في هذا الواقع ما هي مطالبكم بالتحديد
ما
يبقاشيه قالت لدينا الزلزال نريد ان نسكن
نتمنى الرحمه للذين قضوا ومطالبهم هو
ايجاد مسكن ياويهم من برد الشتاء هنا ايضا
مجموعه من الخيام نشاهدها نصبها الناس من
اجل التعامل مع هذا الواقع ودرع درجات
الحراره خلال المرحله القادمه نعم هذا هو
شكرا لك من اقليم الحوز المختار
العدلاوي
ونتابع ايضا من اقليم الحوز مع الدكتور
عبد الملك المنصوري مندوب وزاره الصحه في
الاقليم دكتور هل تم استيعاب واحتواء تلك
الازمه التي نشات عنها هذا العدد الهائل
من الجرحى
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
من الدقائق الاولى بعدما ضرب الزلزال
تجندت مختلف المصالح جندت السلطات المحليه
تجند الاطباء تجمد الممرضون الجميع
الوقايه المدنيه والقوات المساعده
وبتعليمات من جلاله الملك تجنبت كذلك
طبيبات واطباء القوات الملكيه المسلحه
طبعا في البدايات كانت يعني ليست كما الان
استقبلنا مجموعه من الحالات بعض الحالات
الطفيفه التي علجت في عين المكان بعض
الحالات عرفت في المراكز الصحيه
المراكز الصحيه وهي وحدات
يعني
اقل من المستشفى كذلك بعض الحالات التي تم
نقلها الى المراكز
الاستشفائيه الجامعيه الان مجهوده جباره
مبذوله من طرف
الجميع الان عمليه جراحيه تقاموا بعين
المكان
وجميع انواع الجراحات تقام بعين المكان
نظرا لتجمد مجموعه كبيره من الاطباء سواء
اطباء العسكريون سواء الاطباء
القطاع القطاع الخاص سواء كذلك اطباء
مؤسسه محمد السادس ما مدى مساهمه
الفرق الدوليه خاصه منها
المتعلقه بقطاع الصحه والقطاع الطبي ما
مدى مساهمتها ايضا في
احتواء هذه الازمه واستيع ابها بشكل او
باخر
كذلك لا ننسى مساهمه المجتمع المدني بمعنى
الاطباء
المجتمع عبد الاطباء المجتمع المدني
المغربي هناك تضامن واسع
تضامن قوي تضامن كبير من مختلف شرائح
المجتمع المغربي كذلك
وبتعليمات من جلاله الملك
بتوجيه من السيد وزير الصحه جميع الادويه
متواجده بمختلف المراكز الصحيه
بالمستشفى الاقليمي وبمختلف مستشفيات
[موسيقى]
بمختلف مستشفيات الجهه
يعني كنت سالتك عن
المساعدات
والوفود الطبيه والصحيه التي اتت من
الخارج
للمساعده عن دورها في في هذا المجال
شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور عبد الملك المنصوري
مندوب وزاره الصحه في اقليم الحوز
من الرباط اسامه شقور معنا مدير مكتب
منظمه اكشن ايد الانسانيه الدوليه في
المغرب
ما هي المساهمه التي التي تقدم لضحيه
الزلزال من اكشن
شكرا جزيلا نحن كمنظمه المجتمع المدني
نحن في اطار يعني
دعم وفي اطار تنظيم اجابه على مستوى
الوطني لضحايا
هذه الكارثه الطبيعيه
في الواقع يعني الدعم الذي نقدمه ودعم
يرتكز بالاساس على سد الحاجيات
الاساسيه
لضحايا الزجال هذه الحاجات هي تختلف حسب
الافراد يعني هناك حاجات تخص مساحه حوامل
هناك حاجيات تخص الاطفال هناك حاجات تخص
ساكنه
على العموم الحاجات
على المساعدات
الغذائيه على مواد التنظيف وعلامه تطهير
كل ما يخصه ويهمه تغذيه الاطفال الحليب
متعلقه بالنظافه الى غير ذلك وايضا
نحاول ايضا يعني المسائل
من منظمات المجتمع المدني كما فهمت منك
يعني من اين لها او كيف تجمع الموارد التي
من خلالها تقدم هذه المساعدات الان
لضحايا الزلزال
موجوده على الصعيد الدولي لديها في
دراريات متعدده في العالم من الدول
الاوروبيه والغير الاوروبيه يعني
انها تفتح
ابواب للمواطنين في مختلف
البلدان التي تتواجد فيها اكشن عيد لكي
سكان هذه المناطق يساهمون يعني حسب
المستضع لسد هذه الحاجيات طيب كنت تشير
الى
نعم طب الان ما هي الاولويات لدى هؤلاء
السكان
في في منطقه اقليم الحوز وتارودانت وغيرها
من المناطق التي تضررت بالزلزال
الاحتياجات التي توصلنا بها الى حد الان
الى ما يسبب الاحتياجات الخط الاول يعني
يحتاج المتعلقه
بالاكل
بالغطاء بتوفير
السيكل الخيانه وغير ذلك هناك ايضا طلبات
وعد المناطق التي تخص ايضا
تصميم يعني بعض المنازل او بعد الخدمات
الاجتماعيه التي تهم
الساكنه يعني ما هو مقلق لحد الان يعني
سكن هؤلاء الناس خصوصا
نتحدث عن مناطق تتواجد في اماكن جغرافيه
صعبه وهذا تماما السؤال وهذا تماما السؤال
الذي انتظر ان اسالك عنه كيف تتعاملون مع
صعوبه جغرافيه المنطقه ووعوره الطرق كيف
تصلون الى هذه المناطق لتقديم المساعده
يعني نحن كمنظمه كمنظمه من المجتمع المدني
عكس الايد تعتمد في تدخلاتها
على مقاربات
القرب يعني نحن
نتدخل في هذه المناطق عبر جمعيات محليه
التي تعمل في هذه المناطق التي لديها
امكانيه الولوج
الى هذه القرى رغم صعوبات
بتنسيق مع السلطات العموميه الموجوده
في هذه المناطق يعني الاجابه على
هذا الوضع يحتاج الى تنسيق بين المجتمع
المدني وبين المؤسسه العموميه شكرا لك
اسامه شقور مدير مكتب منظمه اكشن عيد
الانسانيه الدوليه في المغرب
اصيب مستوطنين بجراح بعد تعرضي سيارتهما
لاطلاق نار بينما كانت على الشارع الرئيسي
في بلده حوار جنوب مدينه نابلس بالضفه
الغربيه وقال متحدث باسم الاسعاف
الاسرائيلي ان المستوطنين اصيبا من شظايا
الزجاج نوافذ السياره التي تعرضت لاطلاق
النار
واكدت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
التحقيقات الاوليه تشير الى ان مسلحا او
اكثر اطلق النيران من سيارتهم ولذوا
بالفرار ووصل تعزيزات عسكريه كبيره الى
المنطقه واغلق الشارع الرئيسي ومدخل مدينه
نابلس وبشرت هذه التعزيزات عمليه تمشيط
بحثا عن المهاجمين وقال الناطق باسم
حماسنا العمليه هي رد بطولي على اجراءات
الوزيره الاسرائيلي المتطرف اتمار بنغفير
بحق الاسرى ومخططات المستوطنين ضد الاقصى
مهدت اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
الطريقه لتنفيذ صفقه لتبادل السجناء مع
ايران فقد قلت الخارجيه الامريكيه الوزير
انطوني بلنكن وقع الجمعه الماضي على
تصاريح بتحويل سته مليارات دولار من
الاموال الايرانيه المجمده من كوريا
الجنوبيه الى حسابات في قطر وذكرت قناه سي
ان ان بلينكن اكد للكونجرس ان قطر هي التي
ستشرف على صرف الاموال الايرانيه التي
ستحول من كوريا الجنوبيه واقل المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ان توقيع بلينكن
على تحويل الاموال خطوه حاسمه لتامين
اطلاق سراح خمسه مواطنين امريكيين واضافت
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان هذه الاموال
ستستخدم فقط لاغراض انسانيه ونقلت كلت
السوشيال بريس عن مصادر امريكيه مطلعه
قولها ان اداره بايدن وافق ضمن الاتفاق
على اطلاق سراح خمسه مواطنين ايرانيين
محتجازين في الولايات المتحده
وقال سفير الايراني في قطر حميد دهقاني ان
الاتفاق الايراني الامريكي لتبادل السجناء
يمر بمراحله النهائيه واضاف انه التقى
وزير الدوله بالخارجيه القطريه محمد
الخليفي وبحث معه العلاقات الثنائيه بين
البلدين والاتفاق الايراني الامريكي
لتبادل السجناء
بحث سلطان عمان هيثم بن طارق في مسقط مع
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
العلاقات الثنائيه والقضايا ذات الاهتمام
المشترك وقد اكد الجانبان بحسب وكاله
الانباء العمانيه عزمهما المضيه قدما في
تعزيز اوجه التعاون في شتى المجالات بما
يلبي طموحات شعبين وقالت وكاله الانباء
السعوديه ان الامير محمد بن سلمان استعرض
مع السلطان هيثم بن طارق العلاقات الاخويه
بين البلدين وذلك خلال زياره الخاصه التي
يقوم بها ولي العهد السعودي لسلطنه عمان
حملت سفيره الولايات المتحده الدائمه لدى
الامم المتحده ليندا توماس غريفلد القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوه الدعم السريع
مسؤوليه ما يحصل في السودان بسبب ما
وصفتها بالمعركه على السلطه وقالت ان
جهودا مكثفه تبذل في الوقت الحالي لحمل
الجانبين على وقف القتال وستواصل الولايات
المتحده الضغط على كليهما حتى يتمكنان من
انهاء هذا الصراع على الفور واضافت انها
قالت بوضوح شديد للاطراف في جميع انحاء
المنطقه انه لا ينبغي لهم دعم اي من
الجانبين في هذه الحرب غير المعقوله حسب
وصفها
نفت وزاره الداخليه المصريه صحه مقاطع
الفيديو
التي نشرها او نشرها من سمته الوزاره احد
العناصر الهاربه والذي نسب المقاطع
لنزلاء داخل مجمع سجون بدر ووصف الوزاره
مقاطع الفيديو بانها محرفه ولا تمتد بصله
للاشخاص الذين يقولون ناشروا التسريبات
انهم من قاده الاخوان
وكانت تسريبات قد تم تداولها وقال ناشروها
انها من كاميرا مراقبه وترصد الاوضاع في
زنزانه القيادي في جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
محمود عزت الذي كان قائما باعمال المرشد
العام للجماعه كما اظهرت التسريبات صورا
لزنازين معتقلين قال ناشطون انها تظهر ما
سموها معاناتهم في الحبس الانفرادي
اعلن الاتحاد المغربي لكره القدم التبرع
بايرادات مباراه منتخب اسود الاطلس امام
منتخب بوركينا فاسو لصالح ضحايا الزلزال
الذي ضرب البلاد واكد الاتحاد ان عائلات
عن عائدات المباراه ستذهب لصندوق الخاص
بتلقي المساهمات التطوعيه التضامنيه
لتدبير الاثار المترتبه عن الزلزال كما
اعلن لاعبوا المنتخب المغربي لكره القدم
عن تبرعهم بجميع منح المباريات المقبله
الى غايه كاس امم افريقيا المقرره مطلع
العام المقبل وذلك لفائده الضحايا زلزال
الحوز
قرر الاتحاد الاوروبي لكره القدم الوقوف
دقيقه الصمت قبل مباريات الانديه
والمنتخبات حتى نهايه الاسبوع المقبل
حدادا على ضحايا زلزال المغرب وفيضانات
ليبيا واعلن ليويفا تقديم الدعم للاتحاد
الليبي بعد مصرع عدد من اللاعبين في
الفيضانات التي ضربت عددا من المدن
الليبيه
خاضت المنتخبات الاوروبيه التصفيات
المؤهله لنهائيات امم اوروبا
نستعرضها في سياق هذا التقرير
[موسيقى]
واصل المنتخب البرتغالي سلسله انتصاراته
وجاء هذه المره على ضيفه منتخب لوكسمبورغ
بتسعه اهداف دون مقابل ضمن الجوله السادسه
من تصفيات ام اوروبا 2024
وتغلبت كرواتيا على مستضيفتها ارمينيا
بهدف دون مقابل ضمن الجوله السادسه من
لقاءات المجموعه الرابعه
وفي المجموعه نفسها تغلب منتخب ويلز على
مستضيفه اللاتيفي بهدفين دون مقابل
وفي المجموعه العاشره فازت ايسلندا على
ضيفتها البوسنه والهرسك بهدف وحيد سجله
في الدقيقه الاخيره من عمر اللقاء
[موسيقى]